middle chapters usually take beloved
characters to some pretty dark places we
know across the spider verse is the
second part of a Trilogy so does Miles
Morales end up at a low point in this
part of his multiversal journey warning
spoilers for across the spider-verse
ahead
the first half of across the spider
verse follows miles and Gwen Stacy on
Parallel Journeys both struggle to
balance crime fighting with their
day-to-day lives and wind appealing
alone as a result after miles gets
pulled into Gwen's new gig as a
dimensional hopping timeline protector
however things pick up speed they meet
Miguel O'Hara also known as Spider-Man
2099 and his spider Society their
mission is to protect Cannon events in
the spider-verse things like the death
of an uncle or of a particular police
captain miles wants no part to Miguel's
tyrannical plan so he runs but as he
does he learns that his role in this web
is much larger than just being one more
friendly neighborhood Spider-Man stop
what you're doing and stop Spider-Man
Miguel reveals that miles is the
original anomaly that first threw the
spider-verse into disarray because the
spider that gave miles his powers was
from Earth 42 rather than his own
Dimension the cosmic spider balance was
thrown off ostensibly that event sparked
all the multiversal chaos that we've
seen in the film thus far that's why the
spot is such a perfect villain for the
film not only does he possess
trans-dimensional Powers but he's also
the scientist who brought over the
spider that later bit miles the idea
that his Spider-Man transformation
caused more harm than good rattles miles
but he refuses to give up on himself
anomaly or not miles insists at Miguel's
way of thinking is flawed he disagrees
with the idea that certain people have
to die for the universe to be in Balance
Miguel insists that messing with the
cannon only brings destruction even
going so far as to say that miles is the
reason his universe is Peter Parker died
it's also implied and then confirmed
later in the film that Earth 42 must
have suffered after losing its intended
Spider-Man enraged by miles's
Disobedience Miguel goes on a rampage
sending spider people into every corner
of the Multiverse to search for him his
fervor is fueled by his own past
mistakes but it's hard not to see him as
the villain as he himself says being
Spider-Man is about sacrifice it
requires a level of tragedy we see
glimpses of Miguel's own tragic
backstory and how he brought a whole
dimension to its knees by trying to have
a happy life there in hiding at least we
see his version of the story but is it
possible that he's wrong Miguel appears
to be so lost in his own pain and
torment that he's incapable of thinking
clearly so far the spider-verse films
have been about realizing that we can
make our own paths perhaps Miguel can
still learn that lesson somewhere down
the line
after leading the spider Society on a
wild goose chase away from their
headquarters miles sneaks back into the
base and uses the trans-dimensional
portal Tech to go home he arrives in New
York on a dreary rainy night and as he
runs home he's haunted by his doubts and
fears here's Miguel's words in his head
telling him that he's a mistake but he
just keeps running until he gets home
there he finds his mother Rio to whom he
finally confesses his identity as
Spider-Man all is not as it seems though
as Ryo has no idea who Spider-Man is and
Miles quickly discovers that Miguel's
machine sent him back to his spiders
Universe not to his now trapped in a
dystopian world where his father died
instead of his uncle miles desperately
tries to conceive of a plan to get home
the moment he realizes he's in the wrong
universe is a powerful and unsettling
moment there's an uncanniness to his
conversation with his mother that drives
home just how out of place he actually
is even before the truth is fully
revealed just before miles delivers a
powerful monologue about how he's
finally embraced what he's capable of he
conquers the doubts and fears that were
so vivid earlier but now faces his
greatest foe of all himself
it doesn't take long for Uncle Aaron to
discover that something's off about
miles on Earth 42. in short order he
knocks his nephew out and takes him to a
secret hideout where he ties him to a
punching bag miles assumes that in this
universe his uncle is still the prowler
but he's wrong the prowler is Earth 42's
version of Miles having miles literally
confront himself as a little on the nose
and yet it works the Face-Off drives
home how just a handful of coincidences
can completely change the path a person
goes down it also shows that there's
more than one way to conquer your fears
well across the spider verse ending
right after this confrontation it
appears that Miles 42 will play a major
role in the next movie giving the main
character a shadow version of sorts the
playoff of could be a great move to
allow for a deeper exploration of
miles's character as a whole Gwen tries
to follow miles back to his home
Dimension to help him but when she gets
to his house she realizes he was sent to
the wrong Universe remorseful for
betraying him and determined to getting
back she breaks from Miguel's core
spider gang and creates a new crew I
can't one more friend the roster
includes herself Peter B Parker
pravitter prabhakar and a number of
other kindly spider folks most of the
squad from the first film returns to
helper which means spider ham and
Spider-Man Noir will probably have more
to do in beyond the spider-verse Jessica
Drew and spider bites also end up
helping the new crew spider bite has the
option to shut down Miguel's portal
before miles can escape but she chooses
to let him go later Jess locates Gwen at
miles's parents apartment but she opts
not to stop her or even alert Miguel
clearly both characters were touched by
Miles and Gwen's speeches about how
they're supposed to be the good guys
they know that Spider-Man 2099 has gone
too far but they're not sure how to step
away from him without everything falling
to pieces
though he's ostensibly the primary
villain of the whole movie the spot's
rolling across the spider verse is more
unique than that he spends half the film
as a downright doofus the villain of the
weak archetype that Miles makes fun of
him for being but once he discovers the
true potential of his powers he grows
far stronger than anyone could have
predicted but we never actually see the
spot fully manifest his new powers
across the spider verse ends on what
feels like a second act finale with
everything going bad all at once and
most of our characters in Peril the spot
gets a cool spooky new look and clearly
intends to wreak havoc across the
Multiverse but his villainous plans take
a backseat to miles's dimensional
displacement and the reveal of the new
Prowler it will be interesting to see
how big of a role spot plays in beyond
the spider verse though he's incredibly
powerful now he doesn't fully escape the
label of a joke character now that miles
is stuck on Earth 42 it might make sense
to focus more on the antagonist there at
the very least though a climactic battle
between the spider society and the spot
seems inevitable especially since we
don't get one at the end of a cross when
spy man into the spider-verse was
released in 2018 and broke the mold of
both superhero movies and animated
features with its Blended visual style
bright colors sharp contrast and comic
book aesthetic it delivered something
completely new for American animation
and with across the spider verse Sony
has broken the mold once again the
boldest visual choices from the first
film are magnified tenfold in a sequel
backdrop's fizzle and Buzz as if they're
covered in a Technicolor Haze harsh
color blasts every scene echoing the
emotions of the characters and changing
with every cut and of course more
Spider-Man variants mean more animation
Styles all of which meld together in a
mesmerizing tornado of motion and Flair
the ending of across the spider verse
brings all of this visual diversity to
Bear splitting Focus between a half
dozen different dimensions and embodying
all of miles and Gwen's despair in Vivid
Hues there may not be a big climactic
battle before the credits cut things off
but the emotion truly peaks in the final
minutes of the film and it's all thanks
to the animation in a way this is the
film's greatest trick issuing a
traditional third Act in favor of a
powerful emotional Rush that only the
spider-verse style can deliver in
addition to the overarching coming of
age narrative one of the main themes in
Spider-Man across the spider verse is
the relationships between parents and
their children the story kicks off in
Gwen's Dimension where she struggles to
connect with her dad Thanks to their
shared trauma and her secret identity
miles has a similar dilemma wanting to
both keep his parents close and spread
his wings as he puts it later on we meet
Mayday Peter B Parker and Mary Jane's
daughter Peter tells miles that it was
only because of him that he felt
comfortable becoming a Father Miguel
explains that he once tried to join the
universe where he had a wife and child
and that his mere presence was enough to
unravel the fabric of existence that
experience is what threw him into his
current state of brooding and of course
the thing that causes miles to clash
with Miguel is the idea that he can't
save the life of his own father the
death of Parental figures is supposedly
an unshakable aspect of every spider
hero story but miles refuses to accept
that as a fact because across the spider
verse ends on such a big Cliffhanger
this theme of Parenthood also doesn't
get fully resolved there's a nice scene
of reconciliation between Gwen and her
dad but we don't actually know what will
become of miles's father or Miguel can
be dissuaded from his strict ways if
Peter B and Mayday are any indication
though families are stronger when they
fight together the core plot concedes of
across the spider verse involves the
so-called Canon events that are part of
every Spidey story simply by invoking
the term Canon the movie presses
squarely up against the fourth wall
there are a few other overt references
to meta storytelling in the movie such
as during Gwen's Art Gallery battle
against vulture numerous previous
Spider-Man movies are invoked as well
Donald Glover's Prowler from homecoming
pops up a stray joke nods to the
multiversal chaos in no way home and
there are clips from both the Andrew
Garfield and Toby Maguire series all of
this meta commentary as part of the
film's irreverent style it's a signature
of Christopher Miller and Phil Lord's
brand and it fits with the natural humor
of the Spider-Man comics however there
are deeper layers to all the Canon
references the fact that Miguel a
character who's pretty clearly
overzealous and in wrong cares so much
about preserving the cannon could be
read as a jab at the Modern franchise
model franchises like the MCU spend
inordinate time tying everything
together in spider verse seems to be at
least a bit critical of that idea the
concept of Canon also fits with Miles
personal Journey at one point he tells
Miguel everyone keeps telling me how my
story is supposed to go nah I'm gonna do
my own thing his mother repeatedly
encourages him to carve out his own
place in the world regardless of if it's
typical or even if it's canonical it's
all possible that's what Gwen says miles
taught her when talking to his parents
at the end of across the spider verse
she spends a majority of the film doing
exactly what Miguel and just tell her to
do she buys into the idea that there's
only one right way to go about things
and In fairness to her it makes sense
why she thinks that Gwen has clearly
been powerfully lonely since Peter's dad
and she's willing to follow the spider
society's lead as long as it gives her a
home but miles wrecks that entire
framework for much of the movie he also
wants to join the crew but he quickly
learns to trust his gut instead of just
following the crowd in his heart he
knows that being a hero is about trying
to do the right thing even when it might
be impossible Miguel may have
experienced great Calamity in his time
but miles refuses to believe that that
makes it inevitable for everyone this is
where miles's status as the original
anomaly takes on more significance his
mere existence proves that not
everything people think they know about
the Multiverse is true and in an extra
textural sense he represents the idea
that deviations are always possible in
fact according to miles it's all
possible perhaps the most striking thing
about the end of Spider-Man across the
spider-verse is how abrupt it is the
closest thing we get to a climactic
action set piece is the chase scene
through Spider-Man 2099's reality
everything that follows is much more
focused on emotional storytelling than
the action in the end miles is still
tied to a punching bag Miguel is hunting
him down and Gwen is in the middle of
her search for it even the spot ends his
Arc Midway through before he can really
reveal what he intends to do if he
didn't already know that beyond the
spider verse was coming in 2024 the
sudden cut to credits might catch you
completely by surprise across the spider
verse is not exactly a short movie but
it moves quickly enough that it would be
easy to imagine another 30 minutes but
then that's part of the point across the
spiderverse deals with Messy topics
broken relationships unsettled trauma
and a love story that keeps hitting
Roblox
look at me it's a movie about growth and
Independence but not necessarily one
about resolution at the end of bangs no
one is really where they're supposed to
be but they all possess the will and
confidence to get back to where they
want to be and that perhaps more than
anything else is what crossed the spider
verse is really about as compelling as
the messy ending to Across the spider
versus it's also exciting to look ahead
at what could be coming in the third
film Spider-Man beyond the spider-verse
is currently slated for release on March
29 2024 less than a year out from the
across Premiere and given the state of
the Multiverse at the end of the most
recent film the third entry could be the
most exciting yet pretty much every
major storyline is hanging after a cross
will the timing ever work out for miles
and Gwen will the new crew be able to
stop the spot can miles save his father
from a canonical death or will Miguel be
proven right in the end and perhaps most
pressing of all How Will Miles balance
his Newfound superhero competence with
the rest of his regular life suffice it
to say there's a ton of material for
beyond the spider burst to explore 4. it
seems unlikely that Miguel will be a
villain forever especially since several
of his closest allies have already
started to turn against him and since
all the Spider-Man variants from the
first movie come back at the end to help
Gwen it's likely we'll get more of them
next time as well whatever happens
beyond the spiderverse should be a fun
ride as long as it holds on to the sharp
style that's made the series so popular
[Music]
foreign